Here we're going to talk about one
of my favorite topics in this class,
Intelligent Tutoring Systems.
The idea of Intelligent Tutoring Systems
is that we know students learn best when
they have individualized,
just in time feedback,
right there in the context
of the learning process.
They learn best when they have
someone sitting with them saying, hey,
you just made a mistake
on that kind of problem.
Here's how to avoid that mistake for
next time.
Or, great job on that problem.
You didn't make the mistake
now that you made previously.
The idea here is that,
it's not that we don't want to give all
the students this kind of feedback.
We definitely do, but we really
have difficulty doing so at scale.
We can't give every single student
a one on one tutor to have during their
entire educational career.
But with software we might
be able to come close.
Intelligent tutoring systems is
about creating software agents,
that can provide that same kind of just
in time individualized feedback to
students while they're learning.
And because they're software agents,
they're available all the time,
they don't have an hourly
cost associated with them.
They get past a lot of
the obstacles to having one-on-one
tutoring during your
entire educational career.
So in this lesson we'll talk about
intelligent tutoring systems and
some of the places they've
been most effective.
We'll especially talk about how they
exist in two different general areas.
Well-formed problem domains that
have a well-structured problem and
a correct answer.
And more poorly from problem
domains where the things to
learn are a little bit more fuzzy, and
a little bit more difficult to observe.